nous retrouvons maintenant duplex depuis
l'hiver craag notre correspondant en
ukraine bonjour gulliver vous êtes dans
un village situé à 250 kilomètres de
kiev nous sommes dimanche matin comment
s'est déroulée la nuit en ukraine
alors les ukrainiens se félicite de ce
que kiev ne soit pas tomber maintenant
la capitale entre dans une période très
incertaine avec ce couvre-feu qui dure
jusqu'à lundi matin par 7 selon les
autorités ils veulent liquider des
saboteurs qui sont dans la ville on a
des chances de ne pas vraiment savoir
quelle aura été l'opération menée en ce
sens mais en tout cas il y un sentiment
de soulagement ce matin en lisant les
réseaux sociaux l'ukrainien les gens
craignaient que ce serait pire que cela
cette nuit toutefois des troupes ont été
vus dans rare qu'yves la deuxième ville
du pays ainsi que dans personnes une
grande ville du sud la guerre se
poursuit
les attaques russes pour suivre un peu
sur tout le territoire du sud nord
centre et est de l'ukraine et même ici
dans le centre où je me trouve
actuellement à 250 km au sud ouest de
kiev vraiment dans une zone rurale où il
n'y a pas de cible stratégique très
importante je viens d'entendre ce matin
une roquette on pense que c'était un
missile tiré sur une base militaire qui
se trouve à une vingtaine de kilomètres
ici quelle première réaction gulliver à
la décision des occidentaux d'exclure
des banques russes du système swift
c'est est ce que vous voulez les
ukrainiens
oui et je vous cite la réaction de
dmitro couler bas le ministre des
affaires étrangères ukrainien il a dit
je dédie cette victoire aux défenseurs
de l'ukraine il considère que c'est une
victoire de lui et de son équipe en
réalité du travail des diplomates
ukrainiens pour essayer de convaincre
les alliés européens et notamment les
plus récalcitrants comme l'italie ou
l'allemagne qu'elle s'était vraiment la
mesure à prendre la chose à faire de
maître coup les bacs qui dit nous avons
travaillé jour et nuit pour les
convaincre de faire ça et voilà ils
l'ont fait 10 la victoire à ce qui bien
sûr font un travail bien plus dangereux
au risque de leur vie pour défendre
l'ukraine les militaires et les
volontaires qui aident l'armée aussi
c'est vraiment quelque chose dont tous
les estoniens par les mêmes ici hier en
traversée des villages ont parlé aux
gens locaux dans des petits villages des
gens qui sont absolument pas des experts
en finance et beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes nous ont dit spontanément on
veut qu'ils excluent la russie du
système swift s'est symboliquement je
pense quelque chose qui était important
pour l'ukraine pour montrer la
détermination de l'occident de faire
quelque chose contre la russie et de ne
pas accepter ce qui est fait en ce
moment merci beaucoup gulliver kral
correspondante france 24
l'ukraine